beautiful weather across much of the
country today drawing crowds to beaches
and parks and at st. Patty's Day bars
exactly what we're being told not to do
at least not without some serious social
distancing if we continue with that
process we will fail in containing this
virus so every single generation has a
role to play we're asking our older
generation to stay in their homes we're
asking the younger generations to stop
going out in public places to bars and
restaurants and spreading a symptomatic
virus onto countertops and knobs and
grocery stores dr. Mehmet Oz joins us
now host of the dr. Oz Show great to
have you with us sir thanks Shannon I
want to read a little bit of The Wall
Street Journal today they had a headline
called saying a generational war is
brewing over coronavirus saying
epidemiologists are growing concerned
that the millennial pushback against
social distancing and an emerging
generational divide about how the
disease is perceived could undo all
efforts to slow the spread of the virus
and put vulnerable people at high risk
what is your message to the people who
feel young feel healthy and they feel
cooped up well their grandparents went
to war we're asking them to you know
take it easy you know sit on the couch
wash your hands and try to make the
communities that you're in a little
safer I've got kids who are Millennials
and even amongst them we're having a
discussion about this but they all get
it they're smart and they understand
they've got a responsibility to society
and actually want to play that role but
they haven't hear the message straight
up and many of them were chased out of
college they weren't quite sure why this
seems sort of alarmist much of the
country felt that frankly even two weeks
ago and and when you begin to actually
see what happened in Italy is a good
example you feared that the same may
happen here and it justifiably warrants
a lot of the decisions being made young
people often haven't seen that same
newsfeed and I find that when
Millennials get it they really get it
they want to play a role they want to do
just the same things their grandparents
did in their own way and it's not too
much to ask but if you want to go to a
beach make sure you're not with anyone
who's at risk soon after even if the
virus spreads you minimize the damage
but ideally you don't go to the beach
you definitely don't go to a bar where
the
purposes to be near other people yeah
and we've seen this in Florida I mean
it's Spring Break they get you know
hundreds of thousands of people in
fluxing into the state during that some
of the state some of the beaches are
being much tougher cracking down keeping
crowds away but others are not just yet
I want to play something from one of the
folks we caught up with on Clearwater
Beach doesn't seem too worried there's a
lot more people die from the flu and a
lot more people died from swine flu than
coronavirus probably will ever kill
everybody's going to get it eventually
it's a viral infection okay and are you
concerned about transmitting it to
anybody no I'm probably gonna wind up
with it just like you will so doctor how
do you respond to that I mean folks want
to be out and have a good time but some
don't seem to understand the threat
well fifty percent of us will indeed get
the virus we estimate over the next year
but if we all get it at once that's a
catastrophe
that's what Italy is going through now
where they're making decisions about
which of the two pages gets the
ventilator and so that gentleman
unfortunately is terribly mistaken this
virus is very contagious it has shown
its ability to kill
and although the influenza seasonal flu
virus can also be deadly our estimates
is this is several times more dangerous
how much more dangerous depends a lot on
how we manage ourselves and how we are
able to deal with with the isolation
required of individuals who have
problems plus the social distancing that
we're praying or pledging but I you're
already looking at success stories in
China for sure where they were able to
corral this virus in one province the
one province and it with the largest
quarantine every human history if you
look at the other surviving provinces
they didn't get the virus nearly as
badly they didn't have the big spike
South Korea which is not dissimilar from
this country is medical care has been
able to really suffocate this virus
they're already starting to open up
again but if we don't handle this right
but we're not only gonna have to deal
with this for the next sixty eight weeks
it's gonna linger for a long time so I
wish what that general was saying was
right and if we do everything correctly
he'll be closer to right then we would
think if we do it wrong I can guarantee
you he'll be dead wrong well listen you
mentioned Italy and I want to bring that
up because we're hearing all kinds of
reports one out of the Telegraph they
have the headline Italians over 80 quote
will be left to die as country
overwhelmed by Corona
they quoted doctors saying who lives and
who dies is decided by age and by the
patient's health conditions this is how
it is in a war now The Telegraph says
they've seen a document outlining
protocol for how they move forward there
that's got to be your worst-case
nightmare as a healthcare professional
it's the it's his it's Armageddon if
that happens and we're already getting
pretty full in a lot of the hospitals in
New York City so you don't want to push
the system there more than you need to
yes we can build and start almost get
accordion additional hospital beds we
can take over universities and put cots
in there we can I have FEMA come in and
help build new buildings but the
smartest thing to do is to get folks
through social distancing to limit the
number of people present to the hospital
and then if we do this right the virus
starts to die out and if we can get to
the summer where we already have the
weather advantage because the virus
particles swell a bit they don't
transmit on travel so well when they're
when they're swollen well that's
fantastic because then we'll have lots
of time to figure out better solutions
or people who do get sick once they're
already in the hospital we'll be able to
do more to keep them out of the ICU and
keep them without a ventilator and get
them home more rapidly but we need time
and if we behave like Neanderthals and
don't respect the possibility that there
might be a crisis because this happened
in other countries we should think it's
possible then we're gonna get burned and
we're better than that America has
always been able to man up we've always
been able to mobilize this is an
opportunity for us once again to show
ourselves and we're being asked to
sacrifice for you got probably a couple
weeks significantly and then as
restrictions come off maybe by June I
anticipate we'd go back in the water so
to speak well you're right doctor we all
can rise to the occasion and I have
confidence in the American people that
they're gonna be willing to sacrifice to
protect each other and themselves in the
meantime doctor thank you so much for
your time great to see you
take care and stay well